he was the single most successful
investor of the 20th century Time
magazine named him one of the most
influential people in the world he's
worth over seventy billion dollars he's
Warren Buffett and here his top ten
rules for success how can other people
tap dance to work what's the secret of
them find your passion you find your
passion I was very very lucky to find it
you know when I was seven or eight years
old and you know and fortunately my
children have found their passion might
you know one son loves farming like
nothing else one son loves music like
everything else and all three of them
love philanthropy and what they get to
do you're lucky in life when you find it
and you can't guarantee you're gonna
find it your first job out but I always
told college students that come on I
said take the job that you would take if
you were independently wealthy
you know that's you're going to do well
at it if you think you're going to be a
lot happier if you've got to X instead
of X you're probably making a mistake I
mean it guys in the auto you ought to
find something you like that's that
works with that and it and you'll get in
trouble if if you think that making 10
extra 20x is the answer to everything in
life because then you will do things
like borrow money when you should endure
or maybe cut corners on things that your
boy wants you to cut corners on ER it
just doesn't make any sense you won't
like it when you look back on and
half-free things and hiring people look
for integrity intelligence and energy
and he said if that person didn't have
the first two that the latter two would
kill them because if they don't have
integrity you want to dumb and lazy you
don't want them smart and energetic it
never bothered me if people disagreed
with what I thought as long as I thought
I knew the facts I mean there's a whole
bunch of things I don't know think about
I just stay away from those so I stay
within what I call my circle of
competence you know that Tom Watson said
it best he said you know he said he said
I'm no genius but I'm smart in spots and
I stay around those spots well I try and
stay around those spots and I I just
don't have a problem if somebody says
you know you're wrong on something I
just go back and look at the facts and
I think that I think that really is much
more important frankly than having a few
points of IQ or or having an extra
course or two in school or anything of
the sort
you need emotional stability I just read
and read and read I probably read five
to six hours a day I don't read as fast
now as when I was younger but I read
five daily newspapers I read a fair
number of magazines I read 10 Kay's I
read annual reports and I read a lot of
other things to this I I I've always
enjoyed reading I love reading
biographies famous lesson about a margin
of safety that you don't drive a truck
that weighs ninety nine hundred pounds
across a bridge that says limit ten
thousand pounds because you can't be
that sure about it if you see something
like that you go down a little further
down the road and you find whether it
says limit twenty thousand pounds and
that's the one you drive across the
nature of capitalism is that people want
to come in and take your capsules
perfectly understandable I mean if I'm
solving television sets or something
there's going to be ten other people who
are gonna try and sell a better
television set if I have a restaurant
here in Omaha people are gonna try and
copy my menu and get more parking and
take my chef and so on so capitalism is
all about somebody coming and trying to
take the castle now what you need is you
need a castle that has some durable
competitive advantage some castle that
has a moat around and that moat that's
one of the best moats in many respects
is to be a low-cost producer but
sometimes the motors just having more
talent I mean if you're the heavyweight
champion of the world and keep knocking
out people you've got a competitive
advantage as long as you can keep doing
it and it's very profitable if you're
the one that happens to be able to do it
if you can turn out great motion
pictures I mean you know Steven
Spielberg I mean he he he's a fella bent
on and and it has an enormous economic
value you'd be surprised at at my days I
mean they are they're very unstructured
no meetings none I mean I don't like
meetings and I read a lot I wish I were
a faster leader you know I get more done
but i but I do read a lot and I I I'm on
the phone a moderate amount our
businesses run themselves basically out
there my job is allocating capital and
and I that's what I'm thinking
about but I don't like to have things
all packed hour an hour an hour and and
though I are both extraordinarily lucky
I mean we really get to do what we like
to do the way we want to do it with
people that we choose to be around then
they're terrific I mean we we've really
got everything our way and it's a we're
very fortunate and in his world he has
some he has a different kind of pace
than I have but we both love it the way
we do it and and my guess is that were
each the most productive in that
particular mode too because it it it
fits our personalities and and and
aptitudes what kills great businesses if
you look at I do believe in looking at
history and I and I try to I like to
study failure actually and my partner
says all I want to know is where I'll
die so I'll never go there and and we
want to see what has caused businesses
to go bad and the biggest thing that
kills them
it's complacency I mean you you want a
restlessness a feeling that you know
that that somebody's always after you
but you're going to stay ahead of them
you always want to be on the move and
and when you've got a great business you
know like coca-cola wishes there aren't
any like oh girl but but really the
danger would always be the you rest on
your laurels but I see none of that
obviously a coca-cola but that's that
that is the key to to compete the same
way when you've got 1.8 billion servings
being sold daily as when you were
selling you know 10 a day and and that
restlessness that belief that that
tomorrow's more exciting than today you
know you just have to have it permeate
the organization who was Ben Graham he
was your primary mentor model it was a
wonderful man and he was my professor at
Columbia I read his book when I was 19
at the University of Nebraska and I'd
started investing when I was 11 I
started reading about it when I was like
7 so I'd gone through all I read every
book in the Omaha Public Library that
was on by the time I was 12 on investing
in stock market and I had a lot of fun
but I never really found out
never got grounded anything and it was
it was entertaining but it wasn't gonna
be profitable and then I read Graham's
book the Intelligent Investor when I was
at the University of Nebraska and pulled
open the whole thing up to me yeah and I
and I named my my oldest son is named
Howard after my dad Graham Buffett and
then he was a marvelous man I never
expected anything from me in return
Ben Graham in his low and his low teens
looked around and he looked at the
people he admired and he said you know I
want to be admired so why don't I just
behave like them and they found there
was nothing impossible about behaving
like them and similarly he did the same
thing on the reverse side in terms of
getting rid of those qualities you have
given a lot of fabulous advice but
what's the best advice that you've ever
received well I I've received in a
variety of forms per ticket for my
father when I was very young but I mean
he basically I think taught me how to
live not thought I did it perfectly or
anything like that but I mean he was
giving me lessons but he wasn't doing it
by preaching to me he was doing it by
example but basically well the biggest
lesson in a sense I got is the power of
unconditional love I mean I think there
is no power on earth like unconditional
love and I think that if you offer that
to your child I mean you 90 percent of
the way home and maybe days when you
don't feel like it it's not uncritical
love that's a different animal but but
to know you always can come back I mean
either that is huge and right that takes
you a long long way and I would say that
every parent out there that that can
extend that to their child at a very
young age
it's gonna make for a better human being
and you felt like you've got that kind
of unconditional love from your dad I
absolutely did you know there's a
powerful thing there's a powerful thing
thank you for watching I'd love to know
what you think of Warren Buffett as an
entrepreneur let me know your thoughts
by leaving it in the comments below I
made this video because Ray Carter asked
me to so there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile leave it
again in the comments below and I'll see
what I can do for you thank you for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon